we flew him all the way from venice
italy just kidding he took an uber from
hunting beach but still it's pretty cool
he is the number three middleweight in
the world it's marvin vittori on this
week's food truck diaries and i'm
feeding them pizza
[Music]
good to see you man thank you look
fantastic
just staying in shape what are what are
we doing here now you mentioned you do
ride a a road road bike yeah yeah yeah
yeah road biking and i mean staying in
shape in general i i train
all year long you never get out of shape
you don't do the polo costa or the paddy
pimlet and get big between the fights i
used to back in the days and then i
realized it's you know it's a lifestyle
and like i mean the way i am you know
like
i need to keep improving so yeah i can
now like and then i feel [ __ ] like it's
almost like you always want to be ready
like for whatever happens if i'm yeah if
you're too big and the you know who
knows if freaking
you know if freaking uh canonnaire
rolled his ankle or something like all
right victoria you're up my man you know
you gotta be ready to go it's more like
a mental state like physically mentally
like you know spiritually you gotta get
ready you uh because we're talking
inside the studio there you come off i
don't i don't know if people realize
this like you're a big
you're you're big on mental strength
like you're all about you know the
mental power improving constantly
getting better that's the one takeaway
after just chatting with you before we
came out here and it's 107 degrees
you're just talking about you know
there's a repetitive theme about you
always constantly getting better
improving mental strength i don't think
i don't think i've heard you really talk
about that
yeah man i mean
you know like you can be strong
physically and technically if you
if here you're not yeah wired properly
you know yeah
you need to be bulletproof and that's
why like
i believe that's why a lot of people
like
pull out of my fights and like
they don't like to fight with me in a
sense because they know it's going to be
a war and like correct
it's it's intense you know like it's
they know i'm not going to go anywhere
man like it's you're tough on the break
yeah like yeah
you can you can hit me you can kick me
you can do whatever [ __ ] you want but
like i'm gonna keep coming you know it's
a good time to be a middleweight man
middleweight is spicy right now dude i
mean you got a huge fight and it just
got announced it got rebooked obviously
you know whitaker's had some issues and
then it gets rebooked you're fighting in
paris now in september
which i think is it's kind of a blessing
disguise man because you know your
italian fans can much easier get down
there than come to the states or where
the hell it was going to be at so now
it's in paris you know it's first time
ufc is in paris my only knock on this
fight is it's three rounds i feel like
you and whitaker should be five rounds
yeah absolutely i think this should be a
five rounds fight but
yeah man i mean i was when was it the
last time when i was in phoenix i was
getting booed and [ __ ] like this time
just me i'm bringing like a thousand
people just people who came through me
which is crazy so that's great so then
uh
and then all the people that are gonna
come from all over the world so
definitely i'm not gonna be booed in
this one no you better not get booed and
uh for you do you see this as
uh kind of a title eliminator fight you
know what i'm saying so you know
whitaker's staple of division four world
champion obviously you guys have both
lost to izzy so it's like i would assume
the winner of this is the number one guy
i believe it should be and um
i'm gonna go out there
trying everything to look for a finish
and uh you know like if it's that
dominant then i think it should be you
know and for are you a guy because you
know you've lost to izzy twice now are
you a guy that you want izzy to keep
winning so you can redeem yourself and
get that rubber match or the you know
the third fight or do you not care you
know honestly never gave a [ __ ] like
even after i fought him the first time
like
every time he's winning [ __ ] that
[ __ ] you know like yeah but you
know like who cares you know by now like
we proved each other outside of our
fight so who cares you know the other
day like
i don't care like i know i'm gonna face
him again i know for sure there's gonna
be a third fight yeah for sure unless
it's it's gonna run forever but
either way you know like i'm gonna be
champion at one point and if he's
already somewhere else like he'll come
back to face me because he knows like
yeah if you're trying to like i remember
in the press conference he was saying
like oh my you know
my friend died or something i'm gonna
like uh
like uh
you know like do it for him and destroy
yeah dedicate destroy like i came out
with a samurai mask didn't do [ __ ]
[ __ ] run for front for like five rounds
and just like kick me like so but yeah
you can't be happy with that i i think
what's interesting too is your first
fight uh between you and izzy you know
was a split decision some people
thought you did enough in the third
round to get it done
but if you go back and and watch that
fight like the you've gotten so much
better since that first fight with izzy
to where you're at now i think it says a
lot about your work ethic and again back
to what we started this show with is you
keep talking about improving all the
time yeah
yeah no but you see like
he's he's a tricky he's a tricky fighter
man you got to give him that he's weird
experience like
he really like he's he's fighting like a
game so to him there's
not a bit of pressure whenever he walks
into that cage and you got to give him
that because he he deals with it really
like
really like methodically in everything
that he does yeah so
[Music]
he edged me
on the
not mentally in the sense of like uh
toughness or anything like that
but like
on the tricky part of the mental game in
a sense yeah on my last fight and uh
so he was still
on that on that on that set like on that
um
from that point of view he was still
like
on point but i think i would credit that
to you know izzy has been the guy for
quite some time so those big fights
you know it's not that you haven't been
those big fights but for him that you
know defend the titles many times he has
fighting answers like he's been those
big moments so many times you get used
to it so it's an experience iq fight iq
thing but you're getting the title fight
is something different for sure
different animals so
yeah a little bit for sure but i really
feel like
now i pretty much
i mean
basically seen it all so
the next time i'm gonna see him i'm i
think i'm gonna be better under every
[ __ ] aspect and uh it's gonna be good
going back to the first fight what
amazed me for the first fight is that
like
i was so green yes and he still couldn't
do [ __ ] i was i i go back and i'm like
[ __ ] you know i'm baiting like i'm i'm
you're falling for everything like he's
faking me and i'm like reaching big on
everything and i'm like he couldn't
still do [ __ ] yeah and uh
well i don't know
i got more than him you know but
just a process and i mean he's a little
bit older than me he's been in so many
fights so i can see the why
but i'm gonna catch up and pass him for
sure one of the things that
izzy's good at doing is adjusting on the
go also
yeah the top guys like you at floyd
mayweather
you know those first few rounds he's
just downloading data he's just seeing
the way you react to faints and whatever
and then once they download the data
you're kind of screwed you know is these
very similar
mma everything like you gotta shorten
the time on everything because there's
not as many rounds yeah yeah in every
round count because then you know you're
down two and then you gotta win the next
three yeah those top five you know it's
all you know styles make fights and you
know the champ is always gonna adjust to
whatever style and get the job done but
you know when you look at the the
landscape like you mentioned u-verse
cannonaire to me is an amazing fight
stylistically that's a fun ass fight
yeah that's a good one that's a good
yeah i mean like both samples
um
yeah it's just like this guy that relies
a lot on to power to be honest they
don't
they don't end up being well with me i
think because
i can take the power you know yeah and
then they're like [ __ ] like that that's
my best asset go-to yeah yeah and you
you should take that away from me yeah
yeah i think that would be a great fight
i just middleweight is so fun right now
man you middleweights are savages then
uh you guys are good on social media you
get on the mic like you'll talk [ __ ] we
know paul costa's doing his weird [ __ ]
on social media izzy's good at it sean
strickland's good at it you know you
guys are wild boys then robert
whitaker's like whoa mr nice guy
whitaker's like hey be cool man you know
but he's been all over the place he's
talking [ __ ] is he yeah i mean that's
not like robert no but you know like
he's sometimes like like you know put it
out there he's like oh i'm better than
marvin everywhere i'm like bro like what
the [ __ ] you're saying
kind of always in a nice way you know
but
yeah yeah we're gonna talk good [ __ ]
would it get weird for you because you
and uh strickland you know you guys
sparred together you guys are pretty
close would it would it be weird for you
if you guys have to fight they asked us
to to fight and we're like oh you know
they want us to play how long ago
before the pereira fight oh wow yeah
yeah
but it's it's crazy bro because there's
so much [ __ ] going on like behind the
scene with me because me and him
are right are good we have a real
relation but he's good because
it's a weird [ __ ] relation because we
know we might fight one day but we're
still kind of friend but at the same
time it's hard for me to be friends
because i got all these other people
that are friends with me and he's
talking not like you know i got muslim
friends i got like christian friends i'm
pretty like i mean i'm christian myself
not you know like not the most like
religious guy but but still yeah so
crosstalk any and yeah and you'll be
talking all kind of [ __ ] so like oh this
[ __ ] talks to you and i saw you
training with yeah bro like i'm just
he's just good work and i'm you know
it's my friend so but he's hard to stand
with his [ __ ]
with what he says yeah so with sean
strickland it
i feel like it's organic he's not trying
like a kobe covington or something like
that
i feel like it's organic but he's also
you know he knows this stuff is going to
get traction but i don't it doesn't feel
like an act you think it's an actor he's
just firing off at the hip and doesn't
realize the repercussions it's not an
act but how many things that
could be like um
how do you call it like controversial
controversial that that like that you
think but you don't say oh yeah right i
mean my entire life and exactly so why
the [ __ ] you don't but you don't say
them no he [ __ ] says them like so
that's why you know like so part of me
likes that part of me likes that out of
him because i like he has no filter even
though you know he gets lit up for it
part of me is like yeah that's him
though you know whether i agree with her
now i'm like that's him you know
well yeah so
that's it but no so they asked us to
fight and we're like
you know like that's all if for a for a
title fight yes but for if it's not a
title fight then like you know we would
do it for money so let's pay us more and
then like that's the thing you know they
gave me they gave me whitaker which i
was even more happy yes for you that's a
bigger fight right and then you know
with alex pierre
you know for him it you know it's a it's
a dangerous fight but
you know i i've heard around the water
cooler if he were to win that fight he
gets a title shot right i think so or
alex's title shot so
you know it's the fight business not the
friend business you know as much as you
guys are friends it's like you're
telling me and
you can tell you know i'm not being
shitty here but it's like would you
rather have sean strickland as a friend
or be world champion the first italian
world champion you know it's not for
sure
yeah yeah trying ferraris and [ __ ] in
italy you're [ __ ] doing your thing i
can still do that already but yeah well
yeah but you could have more no no yeah
yes sir no it's it's a it's a thing of
mine i sent myself to do it
do you have a ferrari uh no on my own
but i've tried yeah yeah yeah well if
you become champion you should
definitely get one for sure yeah let's
do it they should give me one for free a
hundred dana if he if he wins give him a
goddamn mess f9 peter come on but uh
this this food truck that we got here
it's an interesting story because i was
at a a function with my my kid it was
like a halloween function there's it's
in calabasas and there's all these food
trucks and this food you'll see it it's
just crazy at night it's all lit up and
[ __ ] so i took a picture and i sent to
my guy casey i'm like dude let's book
this food truck food truck i've ever
seen he hits them up they tell us the
price i'm like let's wait let's go ahead
and wait on the food truck and then when
we hit you up you're like yeah i'm down
to do it but i want good pizza so i was
like oh this is the time to bring out
the hitter so we got this special food
truck free i don't hopefully the pizza
is good it better be good you know what
i'm saying better be good for for one
day you go back to fighting yeah man
yeah but one day i'm yeah yeah you can
see me lose another fight but uh
the guy looks tough you know i don't
know man i tell dick jokes now dude i'm
not ready to get punched in the face but
uh let me because your fight's until
september so i can't have you eating a
whole pie but one slice i think we'll be
all right yeah we'll just get back on
the bikes dude yeah exactly so let me
feed you man
[Music]
let's take a little break from chatting
with my italian brother from an italian
mother marvin vittori because man i'm on
the road these days or if i'm getting my
coffee or getting lunch i'm seeing a lot
of dudes out there on these streets with
no hair that's right and this is just
facts two out of three bros will
experience some form of hair loss by the
time that they're 35 how about more than
50 million dudes in the us suffer from
male pattern baldness
thank god for keeps my friends that
keeps i keep telling you bald dudes all
the time
keeps offers simple affordable
stress-free way to keep your freaking
hair all you do you meet with a doctor
virtually all right you don't have to go
in an office there's none of that we
take all the guesswork out of it all
right
and then they approve your medication
and it's delivered straight to your door
every three months you never have to
leave the crib 24 7 care and support we
gotcha it's low cost treatments can
start at 10 per month keeps offers
generic versions of the two fda approved
medications to prevent hair loss
this is the real deal keep your hair
holy filled we got you man they have
everything you need keep scots at all
delivered straight to your door discreet
little package proven results nobody has
to know you're doing stuff for your main
all right remember prevention is key so
if i lost your hair this isn't for you
if it's starting to go you need to do
some asap about it because treatments
take four to six months to see results
so act fast becomes your hair save time
save money spend less
with keeps if you're ready take action
dudes prevent hair loss go to k-e-e-p-s
dot com shop s-e-h-a-b to receive your
first month of treatment free that's
keeps.com shop to get your first month
free
k-e-e-p-s dot com shop now let's get
back to the program how we doing boss
i'm good man yourself we're good man
we're uh my man here asked for pizza so
we called the
fanciest truck we know man sent out that
pizza bat signal came to the right place
yeah your truck is insane man yeah man
one of a kind out here you're the only
food truck i've seen where you guys you
have two levels you like he's standing
up there yeah we're probably the only
one like this in atlanta i've never seen
it we do this all the time but he he's i
hate to put pressure on you he's from
italy hey like born and raised
all right
well the spelling is right is it bananas
okay
yeah all right that's a good sign yeah
what do you uh i mean standard pizza huh
as far as like the decisions um my
personal favorite is i like the white
heat but i like i'm a i'm a meat guy so
i add sausage to it okay um and then
most popular right here on the truck is
the pepperoni and the margarita standard
yep what are you going with i'm my old
school guy like uh margherita is going
to be good
we can we can add some uh get wild
what's it called like um
sausage on it yeah good choice but on
the margarita of course i'll do the
margarita just how it is then also try
the classic pepperoni yeah yeah yep
that's it brother easy peasy yeah thank
you it takes about seven minutes for the
pizzas to be ready okay perfect for you
all right thanks sir
let's do it
[Music]
it's the thing
[Music]
let's ride
[Music]
another little break from chatting with
the number three middleweight in the
world marvin vittori we're we're
chatting up we're handing off we'll be
honest i feel like we're hitting it off
i'm heading off with this italian dude
right now and you guys are watching this
and we're eating pizza but listen
i gotta talk to you guys out there if
you got a bush
you're messing up man ask your girl ask
your dude for that matter bushes aren't
cool fellas they're just not hip anymore
it's not the 70s you got to trim your
bush but you got to do it the right way
my friends at manscape they got you
covered man because taking control of
your bush can be overwhelming i used to
have a bush it was overwhelming it was
like jumanji down there
and i took care of it with manscape
because they got the best nut sack
hitter possible all right save big and
be the most hygienic version of yourself
by using the discount code shop20 that's
seh aub20 for 20 off and free shipping
at manscape.com
we got you man whether you want to go
looking like a bald ego or just need a
safe trim manscape is dedicated to
helping you level up your full body
grooming game not just your nut sack not
just your bush the grooming package
which i recommend i use all the time the
performance package 4.0 inside this
package what is in there brendan i'm
glad you asked well they have the
lawnmower 4.0 the electric trimmer is a
bush's worst nightmare yeah they're
they're enemies because it can trim all
around that bush doesn't nick your sack
you have to worry about there's a light
on if you want to do in the dark while
your girl or man's sleeping nobody has
to know shave down that jumanji bush of
yours all right we got you man it's
basic landscaping when you trim the
hedges the trees stand taller
you know what i'm saying
you don't be an elephant with giant ears
and just a small tusk you know what i'm
saying
you gotta
switch it up that makes sense all right
we got you guys man second best tool in
the performance package is the weed
whacker it's a fine-tuned nose and air
hair trimmer dude i'm telling you right
now i catch anybody with hair hanging
out their nose or their ears
you can't be friends and you can take
care of it very easily with this package
man and they also got a little something
out of pep in your step the crop
preserver it's ball deodorant all right
and they also have a crop reviver spray
on testy toner your nuts will thank you
and with the performance package you get
two free gifts the shed travel bag which
your boy uses when i'm on the road and
the freaking
patented high performance reduce chafing
manscape boxers i love these man they
have a bunch of other products on the
website to help you maximize your
confidence in the grooming game don't be
ashamed of it dude all right get 20 stop
and free shipping with the code shop20
at manscape.com all right you guys got
this that's 20 soft and free shipping at
manscape.com use the code shop20 that's
sch aub 20 it's time to level up
that bush of yours man all right that's
manscape.com promo code is shob 20 for
20 off now let's get back to the
freaking program all right man let's do
it i don't know if it's gonna be well
you've already tried it approval
real italian it's approved it's approved
it's approved now we're uh
if i were to go back to your hometown in
italy which is
where
verbal
you're good man that's the corona
it means a half crown half ground meds
it's nice there huh it's beautiful man
yeah
do you get to go back a lot or no
i was just back yeah
every time i have like
i have a moment i'll be back i'll go
back really all your family's back there
yeah i am
my mom my brothers yeah what kind of
food we eat if we head back there my man
we eat a lot of like um
how do you call the
i mean
my my uncle and stuff they always go
hunting so sometimes they bring me back
like meat from like
deers and stuff oh [ __ ] but um
we eat like many times we'll be laughing
like polenta is like um
corn um i don't know what it is like
them yeah yeah yeah
the yellow yeah yeah yeah
like that and then like kind of like a
stew like we call it like um
it's like a kind of like a stew but
with different spices or stuff in it no
maybe because i'm just ignorant but you
guys are you guys making pizzas or no i
just feel like you're mine
no not really pizza is more of a thing
like you go out and you eat it like it's
like pizza is a very like easy thing
like sometimes when you don't know what
to eat and like you want something easy
fast but it's always good and it's
always like
you know it's never disappointing but
like this is like when i find this type
of pizza in italy or there's it's a
different no you can find some like
so this is good for a truck pizza like
yeah like like
but it's not bad though like you could
eat in like in that you'll find places
that like it wouldn't be like considered
the best pizza but it's not it's not bad
it's good it's good yeah
but in italy there's like some real
pizza out there yeah yeah but yeah yeah
but even in italy like you have
different styles of pizza from like this
from the north to the south
like
like in naples with like
in naples that is like the original
pizza in a sense
it's more thicker with like the
with the outside super thick yeah
i like that like sometimes
more in the north to make it thinner so
you know and then americans got a hold
of it we're putting ranch on it yeah and
then americans like brewing made like
made it fat yeah i made it there you
gotta do it with nice ingredients like
real dough and [ __ ] americans like oh
let's just destroy this one the main
thing about the pizza is to let the
dough rest yeah oh just americans design
for that yeah exactly a lot of these
like places that like they have to sell
a lot
they won't let the door rest you know
and then they it's well up in your in
your
belly and then that's why you feel
bloated yeah yeah dominoes don't have
time to let the dough rest you feel me
marvin yeah
but growing up
a lot of home-cooked meals everything
it's you and how many
how many brothers you have from my
mother and father like just one then my
my my father remarried but so i have
another two brothers two siblings but
growing up just one brother so yeah me
my brother and my mom yeah i am and he's
older no younger younger
would you guys scrap growing up i
actually yeah yeah i forced him to put
like i put him into greco-roman
wrestling and then uh
and then boxing just to get better his
nose up and then
and then he went back to study but he
was tough was he dumb wait he was tough
he was tough but
wasn't his thing so for you he messed up
his nose like three months ago bad now
still nowadays he got his nose messed up
yeah
so so growing up for you it's not like
you know i'm sure it's bigger now
especially with the success you've had
in the ufc but it's not like italy's a
hotbed for mma you know like you're not
known as like a fighting nation it's you
know compared to like you know parts of
russia or i don't know here you know
like fighting or you know especially in
ireland like it's in the in the blood
out there you know so for
for to be italian to grow up and go
oh i want to fight was your friend and
family like who the hell are you talking
about
yeah yeah exactly yeah i mean growing up
i actually played a little bit of soccer
i wasn't good at it
but um
oh yeah for sure yeah my mom was like
what the [ __ ] is he doing like but white
gave you the inspiration to start
fighting your underwear underground so
i remember going across this like this
fader million ankle video man vader
would do it that just
that just that just did something in my
mind and i'm like [ __ ] how about this
guy
you started
the brother and [ __ ]
no actually
so i have a little like uh
little park next to my house and i
literally just started calling my
friends and like let's fight
let's fight and then uh were they into
it there was one guy that was into it
man
and uh yeah we just like bare knuckle
bro like just [ __ ] fighting yeah
kimbo slice style kind of like that but
like we just scrapping and then he's
trying to take me down but like once you
don't when both of people don't know it
gets rough as hell like oh yeah i
watched it super rough man
you're rolling out like then for a
little bit i we start we we kept doing
that coming back with like black eyes
and stuff
and then um
then i'm like maybe i want to start
doing it properly how old are you at
this point
14
14. i mean that's young to get into
fighting so then did you find a local
gym and you're like so i got a ton right
no no no so my i come from like a my my
town is like 5 000 people
so the next city next to my town is like
50 minutes drive
so
there there was a gym and then there is
another city that
they had like a wrestling gym
greco-roman because they're still like
men's do greco and women were doing
freestyle yeah
so i was going to
that time when i was like 30 minutes
away and then
so basically i was i would finish high
school uh 3 p.m jump on a train with my
bike get like 30 minutes away into this
city called roberto get on my bike get
to the gym train there get back to the
train
drive like get get to the train to the
city in the me in in the middle between
that city and my hometown do another
training
and then go back and then that was my
life for like three like two years and
then i moved to london you must have
been passionate about it to be 14
jumping on trains and change over hikes
to do all that
and but you loved it when you walked in
yeah yeah yeah i was like
it was awesome because
in my mind i'm like man because
i was into like uh
i did other like uh seminars before
about like uh martial arts and stuff but
they were like super soft you know yeah
and this time at least they were like a
little more serious like the warm up was
serious and then uh
at least they were teaching things you
know in the beginning once you like see
even basic stuff like arm bars triangles
and you're like [ __ ] you know this thing
really can choke somebody out really can
bring like yeah this [ __ ] can really
break somebody's arm
like
you don't see that in like either like
tradition
unfortunately no no no traditional
martial arts at all yeah it's like
breaking bad
exactly
so i'm like [ __ ] not for real this
[ __ ] can work
and so yeah that got me like or like
real naked choke stuff like that like i
can put somebody out for real and then
so going to those gyms in italy and then
you're like oh i need to up my game here
i'm going to go over to london because
london especially at the time 14 yeah
yeah especially at the time starting to
be a hotbed for mma you guys like biz
being dan hardy coming out there you
know
i went to train
it just happened to like uh i was in a
competition
and i met this guy
and uh he's like
why don't we go to london for like a
week just to check it out who is this
fighter who's the guy
one guy that we were doing like some uh
grappling competition and then he
stopped basically actually i saw him the
last time i just went to italy was crazy
i saw him like randomly he wasn't wrong
was he doing well or
he's doing well but like he's just
doing grappling like amateur now gotcha
yeah
so he so he's like let's go to london up
our game yeah because there's some real
gyms out there and i went to london
shoot fighter and i remember we walking
there we got destroyed man
and after that
they they went on us like they wanna
they wanted to show us the the ropes you
know that's how it was back in the day
like you walk in the gym you don't know
what you're doing they're gonna light
you up so you know but we weren't really
like showing up or nothing like all
right like let me check it out we
weren't really like they were there yeah
i wasn't there to find a point yeah but
they still and i'm glad they did and
then i remember i walk out of the cage
and um
i lay on the mat after nobody's there
and i'm like this is where i want to be
for the next wow after that last week
you're like this is for me
your special breed my man cause i've
been like i'm out of here i'm gonna hang
out with that other guy saw in rome the
other day and did not do [ __ ] yeah yeah
now you're right though
yeah yeah
something so then you just
so then did you move full time to london
start training there and then yeah i
finished high school and then i finished
in june and then like
like by july i wasn't i was in london
they didn't even know english wow
by myself because this guy never came
after yeah and um
yeah because yeah
he's like no dude only guy out there was
one guy that i met that time that i went
it was an iranian guy um
crazy [ __ ] crazy
we came this close to stab each other in
that [ __ ] house so many times
my mom would send me like some some food
from like italy like like to london like
you know like
and i see like i might be i come home
later at night
and this [ __ ] is there opening
up my [ __ ] that your mom's saying yeah
my mom's telling me like
and he's like you're in my house this is
my [ __ ] too like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about [ __ ] like pro
like
crazy [ __ ] it makes sense though
yeah iranians like they they grew up
different bro like these guys like
they're tough i'm from italy like yeah
bro like it's [ __ ] tough man so in
the
iranian wrestlers i don't know if you
had a wrestling background you got your
hands full oh yeah yeah yeah for sure
for sure in london there's like not the
best wrestlers but like in london
there's a lot of right rings wrestling's
not their thing yeah but um
yeah no no no no no the other thing but
so you go from how long was it were you
training in letting london and then you
made the freaking gigantic jump over the
states
because did you realize when london like
oh if i'm gonna do this and actually do
this i need to be in the states
so
i was in london
then eventually
i moved back to italy for like six
months because
living in london was hard like basically
the years like 19 19 to 21 the years
were like
all your friends get [ __ ] up and go
out and party and have fun have a good
time for me we're like
working
and training that's about it
well that's why you where you're at
where you're at now yeah but it wasn't
easy like i'm like
i'm there cutting weight like alone
during the summer and i see these
[ __ ] out and partying like
[ __ ] bastards yeah you probably
questioned yourself a few times yeah
yeah
uh i kept telling myself like one day
one day like you know
so after a couple years um
i had enough of it and were you and were
you did you know so like
through my career where i'm like um
i need a change
so i went back and i'm like [ __ ] i'm
gonna figure it out and then um i
started i started training in milan
and it was good because by the time i
already made a little bit of a name for
myself so they they the gym in italy
saw me a little bit in a different way
they saw that i was literally
different yeah they knew you had talent
and you had to fight and you
now they knew you because were you doing
amateur fights at the time like all
night no i already went pro by then oh
yeah yeah i had like five five six
fights okay undefeated i assume no
so one of the reasons five and one
that's why like okay that's pretty good
the the one i lost
when i lost the fight that's when i
questioned a lot of things
and then i moved back to italy
for six months yeah and then i did a
tournament called
venator which was pretty cool because
for the first time there was this guy
that like invested some good money in it
and um
wanted to go like uh film and send it on
tv kind of like kind of like the
ultimate fighter kind of stuff for italy
so i was in this tournament i won the
tournament
i won like 10 000 euro by the time
and then they gave me another opponent
and to defend my belt
and it was like an international
opponent an english guy actually called
jack mason
and i'm like this guy is really
experienced and in general like like you
said like
i knew that to make another like a
another step forward
i had to eventually go to america yeah
so when i was in london what happened
that what what happened back then is
that like
one time i went to america with my jiu
jitsu to the competition and we ended up
at the cabrinis gym and we met babalu
and then i met babalu there so it always
remained in my mind he told me like oh
you should go out kings and you knew who
babylon was right i knew bible
legend yeah
yeah especially because i was such a
fatal fan and that's right yes
even though he lost but i knew still i
knew that yeah
and then
so i was in italy after six months
no i won this tournament and then they
gave me this fight and i'm like
i need to go and do a camp in in america
yeah
so
came to america
even that crazy story because came to
america thinking one thing
didn't realize how [ __ ] expensive is
california what were you thinking oh so
you came to not only to come to america
but you came to uh california was your
first one you had to try to go to kings
to kings yeah
and i thought you got a place for like 7
800 per month tough
like hell no i like and i i i asked
babalu the bible stop stop replying to
be honest
and i'm like okay now i'm [ __ ]
how am i gonna do it uh so i'm in this
[ __ ] mcdonald's uh getting like the
the wi-fi basically stayed there two
days because i'm like i was just leaving
to go to train
i remember and then come back and like
stay there like 24 hours
at least i had a wi-fi and then i i
scrolled through the [ __ ] numbers
that i had and uh
and last [ __ ] resort was this guy
that's called jason manley i still know
him nowadays
jason manning
yeah one of my favorite people on the
planet yeah yeah yeah i know jason
really yeah yeah bro that guy like he's
one of the main reasons i might be here
today wow because
he brought rachel
uh you know her is uh
his girl now like they have they have uh
she's a fighter too yeah she fought in
that tournament back then in italy so we
met
and he's like he was telling me about
all these things oh i'm training with
this and that like i'm a good friend
with nate but for me it was so far and
i'm like bro this guy's full of [ __ ]
yeah to be honest and we were in the
sauna cutting weight
and i'm like whatever like i'm on my own
and he's talking but then but then he
got really close to my nutritionist
which is also
uh
which i've always been also i've i've
been for like 10 years now almost
and uh
and then last resort i called this i
called jason and he just picks me up and
i stayed with him for three months
basically training with him and jason
miller mayhem yeah also a good dude
obviously you know having an issue but
mayhem really it's so crazy of me man
that
you went through every number and you
know i don't know if you believe in
signs something like that but
knowing jason manley there couldn't be a
better guy he was the perfect guy to
call so
to me i don't know you know i know
you're somewhat religious there has to
be something there where your last phone
calls jason manley and if you gave me
you know a list of a hundred people he
would be my first call to help you out
that's how crazy that is yeah jason
manley's like salty the earth also
complete savage when it comes to jiu
jitsu like mastermind smart guy
businessman like he knows everybody so
for him to pick you up and take you
under his wing is
so insane like the chance of that are so
nuts man
so yeah that's the story
and i stayed with him bro in his [ __ ]
house and i'm like
you know after a little bit i'm like
you know i've got to pay you or
something you know you know like
eventually you know i know how expensive
it is
and i don't want to be like
freeloading yeah exactly and uh no never
asked me for nothing not a [ __ ] thing
that's jason he saw he saw something in
here you know what i'm saying like he's
that type of dude
such a good person yeah you still talk
to him today yeah yeah yeah whenever i
go out to vegas like
and i want to like uh trade some jiu
jitsu like uh
mma wrestling and stuff i always hit him
up and
i'm actually for the second of july
i think he opened a gun store in in
vegas all right
so i think i'm going to be out there
like small business yeah yeah yeah he's
a really smart guy
really really smart guy yeah man that's
crazy
and i'm sure he's still proud of you now
you know right now in the world you
fought for world title i'm sure he's so
proud of you no no for sure we remain in
contact for sure does he hit you up now
i'm like hey man remember when i let you
stay for free i need ten percent
nah he is a business man you know
well man
we have this pizza i think it's pretty
good i don't know it's good you know
back home but for an l.a food shop the
coolest food truck that we've had
uh you almost finished it yep don't
finish it because you have a big fight
coming up in september you win that one
we're going sizzler again and you said
you were going to buy ferrari so that's
cool i'll help you get the ferrari um me
or jason manley well i mean jason manley
has better connection than i do but um i
can't tell you how long we want you on
the show man hopefully you enjoyed the
pizza
you know who we're rooting for here when
you fight freaking whitaker in uh paris
man i think it's just
it's just a special time frame man don't
pick against me when i fight i'll just
sign you again i'll try not to man i try
not to all right it's [ __ ] tough you
know but yeah i know now that i don't
know what i'm saying one version of me
in this next fight that's the key my
brother like you to me like you're such
and we have fighters in all time you're
you're special i know you're a really
good fighter you're special because
you're you're fight iq and you're aware
of what you need to work on and your
ability to work on it and improve those
gaps you'll be world champion man you
know what i'm saying thank you yeah yeah
before we leave and i always forget cuz
ct
you'll know what that's like down the
road but um it's fun it's fun but
we give every fighter a pair of kicks my
man now the i don't know if you're a
sneaker head you came some golden gooses
which i appreciate now these are special
because my friends at suplex i go
alright we got marvin victoria come on
man number three got middleweight in the
world he's from italy
so what could what italian chuka would
do
and so we did our research now these are
the union ii jordans right and union is
a shop like a street wear shop in
california and they do a collab with
jordan they have a bunch of different
collabs and this is their
jordan 2 collab but this is the first
jordan when the original twos came out
that was made in italy so the leather's
italian everything was made in italy and
these are the union versions so
hopefully you dig them they're your size
that's why i asked for your shoe size
i'm not a creep so it says mr vittori
please enjoy and wear these union aj2s
from suplex and the thick boy squad
suplex
beautiful bro pretty dope shoe man so
hope you rock those but there's a
connection because you know your italian
roots your la roots this the cali roots
what is you in your union it's the
collab yeah
nice
yeah if you don't like you always sell
them for a pretty penny
but uh i won i love these yeah i know
but there you go my brother thanks for
doing the show yeah appreciate you man
you're the best brother thank you thank
you man enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
super